I'm shamik Moore and in this universe I
play Miles Morales and Spider-Man across
the spider verse but in Another Universe
my cast mates and I all play different
characters you might be surprised to see
who plays whom
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spider-Man oh you're
supposed to be here at five all right
whatever whatever
wow miles
want to get out of here
this is the lobby Michael O'Hara this
whole thing was his idea you can never
be part of this come on go easy on the
kid he had a terrible teacher Peter
miles later you have a baby I have a
baby
I'll take it from here maybe it's best
to stay in this universe
Spider-Man cross the spider verse now
playing exclusively in movie theaters
ready PG